How many countries are there in the world?
Simple: Just find a map and count it, right? Do not.
Not every map is exactly the same - depending on who you are from, the borders will be different.
So, if someone disagrees, should there be an organization that can solve the problem?
Go to the United Nations to find a room full of different countries, everyone has a small name brand, and then start counting
To get the answer. Of course, the country has come and gone.
When making this video, the answer is 193.
This is the shortest movie, right? You know that this is not over yet.
The United Nations list is not like a student’s book, but more like a club member, not everyone.
For example, the Vatican is a country. But when it comes to being a UN member
It’s too trendy for them
The situation in the Vatican may be a bit complicated, but it is already easy to understand.
If it is with other non-members of the United Nations... or "places"
The words will be a bit fuzzy.
Like Kosovo, she wants to join this UN club, but the requirements for membership are these five countries.
There is no objection inside. Although the United States, Britain, and France believe
Kosovo is a country, but Russia and China think she is only a part of Serbia’s rebellion.
Therefore, she refused her loan. For others, only just over half of them recognize Kosovo’s independence.
Kosovo, very cute, has a web page that uses the language of the other party to thank each country that recognizes itself.
However, Kosovo is not the only one. "Place" wants to be regarded as a real country.
Others are [ along the Dniester River], [Republic of Nagorny Karabakh], [Abkhazia], and [South Ossetia].
See who you ask, they may or may not be part of [Madova], [Azerbaijan] or [Georgia].
Two of the countries... have not been recognized as a state by any UN member state, and the other two have only five supporters.
However, these four places have their own recognition of each other's national status.
There are also [Western Sahara] and [Northern Cyprus] each with their own supporters.
At this time, you may think, "OK, honestly, how do you do it? I don't care about these guys.
When these are not countries, are these places really countries? If I go to one of the resorts
Will she "like" a country? The answer is, "Maybe."
These countries are autonomous (to a certain extent) and have a government that issues passports.
Although these passports are of limited use. And, see which country you go to
They may have more or less control over the territory they claim.
You may not be able to find a clear boundary.
The reason why a lot of these...the place is a bit fuzzy is that they* are usually*
Born in a more recent conflict.
This answer may not be helpful in your imagination, but you can think like this:
The United States is now clearly a country. In 1776, it was not very good. At the time she was just a
The concept in the minds of a class of opposition bastards. She was not immediately recognized as a country, if there was no diplomatic effort
The young United States may not have come by itself.
It’s like a century after she had a rebel. (Annotation: Refers to the Confederacy)
Unlike her sister, she lost in the diplomatic department, so... yeah.
In this way, there are many "probable" countries today, and they may be future countries.
Like the United States, maybe they are the future Confederate States, but it’s hard to say now.
Because these things have to be solved for decades.
By the way, these “possible countries” are super-processing for other countries.
Your small island country may be too lazy to pay attention to the land far away from him.
You still have to decide whether to send or not to send a diplomat, that is to say
No action has been made for every territorial dispute in the world*.
One of the most embarrassing examples is... Taiwan...oh, sorry, Chinese Taipei, *completely* is part of China,
No one will question... (Is China gone?)
OK: In any reasonable definition, Taiwan is an independent country and has been maintained for many years.
But China just refuses to let go and insists that you call her "Chinese Taipei", and don't forget
Who produces your clothes, cutlery, TV, phone, computer, and everything.
So almost all countries, including the great America, are also happy with her.
Although the United States unofficially recognizes Taiwan’s independence and does something unreasonable without such knowledge.
For example, sending an aircraft carrier to protect a part of China and avoiding China’s
Another part of the threat? ?
Therefore, an innocent "how many countries" problem led us to a big "third world war:
Click here to start the button, this is a bit frustrating, so it is better to continue to go...
Oh... yes.
::唉~::
Stop talking about politics: talk about the higher level concept: the Olympics. From the height of the gods,
There is no interest in the country at home. "How many Olympics are there?"
Two hundred and four? clam?
But the Olympics are a bit...special. She defines [Puerto Rico] as a country,
Although she is undoubtedly part of the United States, there are [Bermuda] and [Aruba].
Associated with the UK and the Netherlands, there are a bunch of other places willing to
As a "participating country" to participate in the Olympics, but did not claim independence.
It is conceivable that the Olympics include these to increase the number of members so that she can speak "more than 200
National competition! But this water-filled list does not include the Vatican.
Because of his demographic composition, it is impossible to obtain a gold medal without the help of God.
And the Vatican is bringing the problem back to the heart of the puzzle:
It is impossible to have a consistent definition of the "country" because your list should contain
The Vatican, a country that is the least like a country but still a country, must be eliminated at the same time.
The opposite of the Vatican: Hong Kong, a country most like a country, is not a country.
And don't forget to mention some seemingly infinite "territory" in the last time.
It seems like an independent country, but it doesn't matter.
And this has not included the flag that is inserted on the island or the oil rig.
Printing a banknote with an inkjet printer at home and claiming that a virtual country is
Independent country madman
Then there is no list to follow, then where are we? The best answer to this question is:
In the foreseeable future, the answer to "how many countries in the world" can be said to be "about 200".
Then just like this.
To be accurate to a few more values, it means that there is more than the reality.
Because, after all, the reason why a country is a country depends on other countries
It is a country.